all right one thing that we know will
happen it's just a matter of time there
will be an 18th week i'd be stunned if
there isn't the only way there's no 18th
week is if somehow magically everyone
gets this thing buttoned up and everyone
goes home and stays home and every
player is sequestered in his own room
away from any other family members
because without a home market bubble
people are going to catch it all it
takes is one more game well not what
because like the bye weeks you still can
make a little flexibility right if it's
a team where both teams involved still
have
their buys yeah but six teams have
already had a buy each passing week
there's going to be more
one game that needs to get postponed
where one of the two teams has already
had its buy
that's that's the first game that's
going to land in week 18 and it's coming
and the nfl is admitted
look we want to get everything within 17
weeks but it's there it's got to be
there otherwise you cancel the game
that's your two options a week 18 or you
cancel the game they'll go with the week
18. no i i mean it sounds like you know
yeah they're certainly open to that it's
you're right i mean we're
teetering on the edge of that is going
to happen that's unfortunate hopefully
the last week we'll get everybody back
on their p's and q's but i don't even
know like you said i don't think that's
really going to matter you know p's and
q's are not just any experts you listen
to
you know yes this is the time of year
we're seeing numbers go up everywhere to
where i just don't know
no matter how good the protocols are how
strict you are
you know the virus is undefeated that
way you can't totally stop it
as to the possibility of a home market
bubble
that is something that i think continues
to be the subject of a stare down
between the league and the union the
league does not want to make a
concession to the union to get all
players to live around the clock for the
remainder of the season in a hotel the
players don't want to do it and the
league thinks that the players
eventually will want to do it if and
when games are canceled the union thinks
that the league will do everything it
can to keep games from getting cancelled
so they continue to have that that
face-off
playoff bubble is being discussed
and i think by then oh the union more
likely to agree right players more
likely to agree they're looking at the
possibility chris after the wild card
round of everything being neutral site
with la and dallas being considered this
is from the athletic la and dallas being
considered as locations for a playoff
bubble now i don't know whether it would
be an afc and an nfc or whether you just
put everybody in one
uh because you know you i don't know how
long it takes to reset between games my
guess is they would have afc and nfc
bubbles because you know the way the
games go you have one right after the
other one you've got locker rooms you're
gonna clear out the locker rooms and
clean them and then bring everybody in
you need more time like they did in the
nhl games they had like 90 minutes
between games so i think there would be
an afc and an nfc maybe la for the afc
in dallas for the nfc yeah no i mean
i'm all for that that has to happen that
has to happen i mean to me that will be
like one of the downfalls of everything
if we play the playoffs where it's all
all over the place and everything
that'll leave a nasty taste in your
mouth to where if you're like wait one
team played two games and now had to
take three weeks off so other teams who
messed up and you know got coveted or
whatever i mean all of a sudden the
playoffs get drawn out over seven or
eight weeks like that would be a
disaster
bubble for the playoffs i really hope
that happens it's the only way i think
to ensure just total safety and the most
important part of the year for the nfl
team and yeah they'll have a little
extra time to clear the field like you
said but there's more than two locker
rooms in the these new stadiums like in
la and dallas too to where i bet you
there's four eight maybe even that many
locker rooms that are pretty nice one
being like a crown jewel locker room
right but but if it's if it's division
around and beyond you you don't need
you don't need multiple locker rooms
multiple games it would be one game a
day it would be an eight oh yeah you're
right that's all there is saturday and
an afc game on sunday as long as they're
doing that yeah yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports